we're here at atnt stadium the home of
the five-time super bowl champion
dallas cowboys the most valuable sports
franchise
in the world and today we're gonna learn
how to implement a game plan
to take it from the field to make you a
hall of famer
in business how about them cowboys let's
talk money
all we talk is money all we talk is
money
as a former elite college athlete i know
there's a bunch of similarities between
being an
athlete and an entrepreneur so whether
you're the captain of the team or the
water boy
everyone has a role to play and whether
it's a fastball
or a sales pitch there are lessons you
can take from the field
to propel you in business so here are
the top ten
number one you gotta have a game plan
winging it
only works if you're ordering wings in
sports there's a playbook
in business there's a blueprint either
way
you need to stick to the script and
implement the system
you've never heard an athlete say i
don't really know what we're going to do
today i don't know what they're going to
do today
i guess we'll just get out there in the
field and guess we'll just see that
never happens
winning athletes are always talking
about how they
executed the plan and that's why they
won in the nfl
tom brady executed bill belichick's game
plans and now they have more
super bowl wins than any other coach and
quarterback combo
of all time in the nba phil jackson and
his triangle offense system
have won the most nba championships of
all time
so if your company doesn't have a
defined system and process to follow
your players will be running around like
it's a rec league game and you're going
to lose
so get you a game plan number two
practice
isn't optional there are zero
professional athletes that don't
practice i know what you're thinking
we're talking about practice
practice not a game not a game but
practice
even though ai didn't want to talk about
practice believe me
his ass was practicing at six foot 160
pounds
you don't become an nba all-star mvp and
hall of famer by not
putting in the work when no one's
watching if you're not diving further
into your skill set you're rotting like
a banana in the sun
melting like a chocolate bar in your
pocket
you practice so you never get caught off
guard if you're practicing and studying
the competition
nothing will surprise you failure is
going to happen we all know that
and you're going to want to fail in
practice and not when the world is
watching
in business you practice by studying
your presentation a couple times
before the pitch meeting yeah you're
working on rebuttals for your sales job
yeah
or you're doing research and studying
the competition either way
put in the work and pay attention to who
else is practicing on your team
those are the teammates you can trust in
a high pressure situation and like kobe
once said
you wasn't with me when i was shooting
in the gym go get your ass in the gym
get your shots up so you're calm and
collected when it's game time
number three talent ain't enough talent
is like being attractive it might give
you an edge
but it's not everything no matter how
naturally gifted you are
you better be prepared to work your ass
off as legendary soccer coach
alex ferguson put it hard work will
always
overcome talent when natural talent
doesn't work
hard enough brilliant alex we've all
seen the first round picks
turn into a bust these amazingly
talented athletes fizzle out like a
cheap firework
and you wonder what the hell happened to
them oftentimes what
was going on is that behind the scenes
they were not putting in the work to
improve
if you really want to succeed it needs
to be an all-day
every damn day grind the best of the
best
are not normal they're crazy
that you know every day i'm hustling
kind of vibe
shout out to ricky rosay and as the
distinguished 21st century philosopher
the big aristotle puts it there are
seven days in a week
and someday isn't one of them so ask
yourself
do you really want to be successful do
you have successful habits
are you waking up and getting to the
office early are you staying late
are you sneaking out at 4 59 and part of
the 459 club
trust me your coach or your boss knows
number four listen to your coach coaches
and bosses are different but a trusted
mentor
is invaluable and just like sports
there's normal bosses
unconventional bosses the difference is
in sports
coaches communicate strategy from the
sidelines and they let the players
handle the execution
on the field but in business managers
step in to handle difficult situations
from time to time
but the more a leader can invest to
teach new employees how to do the right
thing in the short term
the more they can handle it in the long
run as legendary ucla coach
john wooden who has the most ncaa
championships
of all time he puts it he says a coach
must never forget that he is a leader
and not merely a person
with authority respect to mr wood number
five
goals are clear every team has an
expectation there's no coaches saying
well
we don't really got much goals this year
we're just kind of happy to be here
no there are clear defined goals win the
division
make the playoffs championship or bust
the same goes for business whether it's
six figures
500k or a million in profits whatever it
is
set your goals and strive to reach them
when employees are given transparent
information about the company's goals
and how their position fits into the
bigger picture they feel more empowered
and find greater meaning in their work
and once you establish your goals it is
up to you
to make it happen michael jordan says
some people want it to happen
some wish it would happen others make it
happen
so go make it happen number six
how bad do you want it everyday athletes
wake up and choose to work
instead of going to brunch or hitting
the scene the reason top athletes are
good at their sport
is because it's their priority they
understand that's part of the process
joel knows what i'm talking about the
most important thing to have is a
winning attitude as the legendary coach
vince lombardi said
winning isn't everything but wanting to
win is
if you prioritize your business you're
set yourself up to win
there's always gonna be a distraction a
party a dinner an event
fomo will always kick in but don't worry
about that
making sacrifices with your time and
energy is what it's all about
leisure can wait the sacrifices you make
now will pay
off later muhammad ali was spitting bars
when he said don't
quit suffer now and live the rest of
your life
like a champion number seven play to
your strengths the riches are
in the niches double down on what you're
good at and hone
your skill set unless you're a two-sport
sensation like bo
jackson you're gonna have to pick a path
lebron was pretty damn good at football
but he isn't playing for the browns he's
in the league become
a specialist and be known for one thing
this is how you maintain
a competitive advantage here are a
couple examples in the nba
my homie duncan robinson right here is a
three point specialist
he broke the miami heat record for three
pointers in a season
this guy takes a thousand shots a day
and my guy right here marcus smart
is a defensive specialist he is
consistently on the nba
all defensive team he's the only guy i
know that practices
taking charges but he can't guard me in
business
make sure you have a specialty and
you're not just a jack of all trades
i live in miami i can't tell you how
many people i know that are dj's but
they're also realtors
and they also kind of bartend on the
side but they also do photography
and they have a crypto fund they want me
to invest in pick a lane buddy
once you make your money and carve your
niche then you can branch out
the riches are in the niches number
eight tune
out the haters haters on my motivators
bro
in the sports world you're always gonna
have the naysayers the trash talkers
and the people who are booing you
straight in your face that's exactly
what happened to my good friend chris
humphries
he was the talk of the town when he
married kim kardashian then
when the relationship ended he became
the most hated man in the nba
he got booed for years it was actually
kind of hilarious but he didn't let that
affect his play or his mindset he lasted
13 years in the nba earning over 60
million dollars
guess who's laughing now so what can you
learn from all this
although you might not be marrying a
kardashian you're going to have your
fair share of haters your friends will
say you can't do
it competitors will talk trash you'll
even get some bad reviews on yelp
it's part of business the question is do
you let
adversity get to you or do you thrive in
it the key
is staying positive and learning how to
deal with pressure the late great kobe
said
everything negative pressure challenges
is all an opportunity
for me to rise remember no pressure no
diamonds
no diamonds no rings number nine no
position is forever
every player needs to earn their keep if
you're not delivering the team will look
to replace you this is true for an
athlete
an executive a salesperson or any
employee
there's always a guy working his ass off
to take your spot
and if you're not doing your job right
the nfl stands for not
for long in sports and in business it's
what have you done for me lately anyone
can have a lucky year or two
but luck doesn't work for a decade
longevity
that's putting up numbers year after
year year in
and year out that's what sets the good
apart from the great
andrew luck good player tom brady
the greatest number 10 handle wins and
losses appropriately
look you won't always win and that's
okay
think of michael jordan he said i've
missed more than 9 000
shots i've lost almost 300 games 26
times i've been trusted
to take the game-winning shot and missed
i failed over
and over and over again and that is why
i succeeded
that's some pretty deep stuff from mj
when you win don't go ballistic
act like you've been there before win
with class and accept success with
humility and if you lose
don't punch a hole in the wall bro don't
throw a golf club in the water
or break your racket learn from your
losses and experience defeat
with dignity to be deeply affected by a
loss is not an option
in sports and in life adam sosnick
my two cents no matter what sport or
business
no one can do it alone make the team
more important than the individual
and you will see the results you want to
be the ideal team player
patrick lincione says there are three
virtues
that make an ideal team player be humble
be hungry and be smart humbleness
means you care about the greater good of
the team above yourself
and you're able to share credit hungry
means you have strong work ethic
high standards and you're willing to go
above and beyond and smart
not iq but eq are you people smart
do you ask questions and do you listen
and you work well
within the group dynamics so take a look
in the mirror and ask yourself
are you an ideal team player hey thanks
for watching tell me what you learned
from this episode
down below in the comments and as always
save that money all we talk is